Manchester by the sea is directed by
Kenneth Lonergan and stars Casey Affleck
and Michelle Williams and is the story
of an uncle whose nephew loses his
father and to his surprise he's suddenly
facing possible guardianship of his
nephew which to him is not the greatest
scenario because he has a very tortured
past as you begin to discover as you
watch the film now where am i I'm
currently in the schmoes no office in LA
I came out here to do some stuff for
them and they were gracious enough to
let me film in their studio so thank you
to schmoes if we don't know who they are
I mean come on just type in schmoes know
on YouTube and you'll find out I saw
this film last night at the ArcLight
theatre here in LA and I was blown away
but the first 30 minutes or so I wasn't
really sure where this movie was going
Casey Affleck works as a handyman /
janitor and at first he's a rough guy
too like for a long time you're sort of
watching the movie wondering why am I
supposed to like this character without
spoiling anything he has a really good
reason for hating life and once you
learn that it really opens up the entire
film for you for me personally the
entire film changed from then on and the
movie just floored me it swept over me
entirely it's the type of film where
each scene just builds and builds and
tension and drama is heaped in piles
upon all of these characters and the
film also has a very clever and
unconventional way of explaining its
backstory it takes you actually a few
scenes to realize you're watching the
past whenever it does flashback to the
past and the only real notification at
first is that Casey Affleck's hair is a
little more messy it doesn't talk down
to the audience in that way it trusts
that you will understand that what
you're watching is in the past and begin
to pick up on certain things that are
hinted at later in the movie and you can
sort of connect the two storylines and
it becomes so much more emotionally
impactful that way and this film took me
for an emotional ride it's a tough watch
the performances are heart-wrenching
Casey Affleck gives the best work I've
seen from him since Gone Baby Gone a
very underrated movie and very
underrated performance from him and Gone
Baby Gone
but this is definitely his best work and
I can see him getting nominated for bed
actor largely because of how subdued he
is there isn't a moment in this movie
where he's saying look at me I'm an
actor I get paid millions of dollars I'm
a big famous person yay look at me I
should get Awards
he's so subtle this is a master class in
subdued acting his performance doesn't
tell you how you should feel it doesn't
tell you how he feels you read between
the lines and you can insert so much
emotion into his silence and just the
subtle little movements and facial
expressions he makes really make his
character explode in this movie Michelle
Williams is not in this film that much
she's definitely supporting but when
she's in the film she's great I gotta
say the performances in this movie were
so real that I honestly felt like I was
eavesdropping on real conversations for
a large portion of this movie I honestly
felt like I could watch five hours of it
because it doesn't feel like it has a
standard one two three act structure it
all just sort of bleeds together and
when it ends I felt like I could have
watched more because the characters were
so well realized the performances were
so good and the situational drama that
gets created around Casey Affleck and
his nephew played by Lucas hedges very
well by the way all of that just builds
to such an emotional crescendo that when
I left this theater I just took this big
breath of fresh air and felt revitalized
by such a well acted and well-directed
drama and well written the dialogue as I
said super realistic nothing about this
movie feels like you're watching a
Hollywood film it felt like I was
peering through the looking-glass at
real conversations as for negatives I
suppose sometimes the pacing is a little
slow and on re-watch that might be an
issue those first 30 minutes where I was
like I don't know if I feel this
character on re-watch I will definitely
like a lot more now that I know what's
going on with his life if you have an
interest in acting this film is a
masterclass in it watch it just for
Casey Affleck Michelle Williams and
Lucas hedges everyone is extremely good
in this movie it's a very well directed
and well-written movie and I'm going to
give Manchester by the sea and
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and thank you to the schmoes
letting me use their studio there's a
link to their channel in the description
below you guys are the best thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes